but now speaking of Jackass yeah you're
a hands down the the MVP of Jackass
forever I don't think there's any
debating that well thanks I mean God
like that anybody's seen that movie he's
like oh my God danger Aaron and the cup
test and what you did to his balls yeah
well when we went into filming I told
the guys I said hey I can't break my
neck again because I've done that three
times
um and so I was thinking about other
ways to you know use my body or and
since we when covid happened we could no
longer do man on the street stuff I have
tons of rad stuff written for like
pranks and man on the streets and all
those just went away instantly when
covet hit so we just focused on
ourselves destroying ourselves right and
so I'm like I'm not gonna break my neck
um
and actually about three oh yeah good
good call crack a little liquid death
refreshing sticks hey sticks how are you
doing out there sticks
one of my homies
um
and so we just focused on like
destroying ourselves and I'm like I
can't destroy
my neck or my knees I might have a knee
surgery so at the time I was like well
uh I was thinking I guess you know we'll
just focus on my dick and come to find
out so like three weeks before
Francis and God who punched me in the
balls in which was test number one which
was test number one uh I had uh already
found out that I was my like Lindsay and
I were pregnant we were having a child I
kept that a secret the whole time we
were filming because
if you they know if if everyone knows
I'm gonna have a baby already and I'm
already sending it hard on my dick
they're gonna just be like well let's
just rip it off right because you've
already used it in a sense you know but
I don't think I don't I don't think I
could I couldn't have done any gnarlier
though I don't think that would have
changed the outcome I don't think that
sensitivity to your like ability to
procreate was really in the equation uh
but dude I remember when I remember
showing up to the set like uh probably
the first week after we got back from
covet if not like the first day yeah and
uh and and I'm a humongous fan of UFC
and they're like dude Francis inganu the
[__] UFC heavyweight at the time he
was the number one Contender now of
course he's the champion yeah he's gonna
punch danger Aaron in the balls for the
cup test and and I as soon as I heard
that
I said please let me have this bit
please please let let please let Francis
and Garner punch me in the balls oh my
God what an honor that would be so rad
and they said um they said no do you
want it too much yeah
I hate cream I'm ice cream I love bee
stings
um we don't need to sting them with any
bees exactly but but okay let me ask you
a question they said that you had your
neck issue yeah you know they said you
had your neck issue they said knock so I
just had a like a hernia surgery yeah he
wasn't doing it he couldn't get hit like
that in the nether regions and uh they
just shut me down they're like no and
then as I came to learn that it was
Francis and ganu and then it was with
the bowling okay so let me ask you like
I'm so glad I didn't [__] yeah
so my question to you is okay the
Francis and ganu bit happens would you
have wish you did that if it had led
into all the other things I did no no
I'm so like I said I'm so glad I did not
[__] do that oh my God can I ask a
question how many times did they attempt
each like so Francis punch was three
times the first time I flinched a little
second time I think he just held back
and punched me kind of in the stomach
and third one was the nail but like the
softball test was I think 14 times and
my legs yeah like I still have this they
used a lot of that like there's so so
many times when things are shot over and
over and over and over and over and they
only use one time and that's like since
they're heartbreaking I know it's like
the like when I did the hockey the
hockey okay so I think they used just
about everything the hockey was so so I
went from Francis to the softball 14
times blasted me looked like a left like
a cheetah print and then immediately
after that an hour later because I I
told Jeff I'm like I was thinking
softball were the same day yeah nice
because I I was in so much pain so nice
I don't want to sleep on it and do it
tomorrow let's just do it now and they
were like are you serious I'm like yeah
get Dave let's let's use that pogo stick
let's go right over there and have him
just jump on my dick and I know we did
that
twice twice the first time it it he
missed like he he had my the cup not
been as big as it was I mean it was soft
though but it but it was much bigger
like surf surface area had he not hit
the cup and it went into my skin I think
it possibly could have went through my
body because if you think about the
energy of a pogo stick it Springs off of
whatever it lands on so it would have
just compressed right through my my skin
right through my body so are you sitting
there with one ball right now or did you
no when he did land it on on my on the
cup right on my nut it was on the right
testicle and it exploded the right
testicle so then it was bleeding and I
had to rush to the hospital then when I
was there there's you know I went and
saw a specialist like later on like two
or three days later and then I had to do
follow-up visits like every month for
about four months just to have them
check to make sure that if the this the
testicle itself was healed because if
blood gets into the testicle it kills
all the sperm but I was already having
kids so yeah Cedar little Cedar Moon so
you're done having kids I'm guessing no
I'm cool I'm sure I could have more Dave
only has one dog one nut David has four
kids did they test your sperm count
after all that when you're going to the
doctor for all that no testing of sperm
counts I'm just you know fingers crossed
I don't want to know I think that clip
was awesome but not as awesome as my new
book a hard kick in the nuts what I've
learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions which is out September 27th
and if you pre-order it right now you
can get the autographed copy so get on
it man pre-order my book it's not gonna
waste your time because I'm proven dude
New York Times best seller my first
book's Five star rated on Amazon and I
have no doubt this one will be too so
get the autograph copy right now by
pre-ordering it at Stevo dot com
yeah dude